jessica is with us in Texas hi Jessica
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
how are you better than I deserve what's
up yes sir so okay where to start my
husband and I are having a hard time
figuring out what to pay first
so I've listened to your podcast I'm
upside down I was Gavin bought at Tahoe
less than a year ago the payments about
$900 the interest rate good boy
I know my interest rate might be at 15%
I mean it might be between 13 and 15
percent but we're trying to get rid of
it I don't try to get rid of it I'd get
rid of it oh I trust me you talked to
somebody earlier you were saying you
hope it blows up when you start it
that's me but I did for some guys I hope
I'm not in the car but yeah we're trying
to figure out we tried to get rid of it
or upside down about there well if we
vote trade it in is 13,000 if we do
private sells about 5,000 or good but so
we have that in cash we have about 6,300
in cash and savings so we've been kind
of holding off for that but we have a
hundred and thirty seven thousand
dollars in debt including the car but we
also adjusted our taxes and we already
owe the IRS twenty thousand my husband
does from an old self employment issue
with his CPA and we're making payments
but we did our tax return this year and
it's the bills coming in at about nine
thousand
how are you missing your taxes so far
every year so it would side hustles last
year we didn't want you didn't save any
money you just says had any money for
your taxes well I'm because we got
married we under shot that allowances
like I was I was writing off a lot of
allowances and so was he and then when
we got married we didn't change anything
and I had had mine from when I was
making oh like so like what is your
household and we make a hundred and
forty two thousand net okay
this is this is this is the first of
February not quite
you need to have $9,000 saved to pay
your taxes extra by the time your tax
bill comes due April 15th and you can do
that with your income you have the money
already saved to get rid of the suburban
get rid of the freaking suburban it's
absolute insanity okay now you got rid
of $9,000 and you just got rid of what
are you owe on that stupid car Oh
30 36 thousand on the Tahoe that's all
okay good we'll get rid of it okay so
now we got rid almost $45,000 worth of
debt right and those two things that's a
big move that gets you started really
really well and then I would go from
there and start your debt snowball
20,000 probably put that the front of
your dad snowball but that's after the
9,000 and after the Tahoe is gone yeah
those two things have to happen by April
15th and with that car gone and then and
that tax bill from this year gone and
don't replicate this problem that's two
times you've had a problem with your
taxes learn your lesson figure out and
start setting money aside when you're
doing a side hustle you you don't use
all the side hustle money you need to
calculate your taxes accurately as
you're going along so you don't find
yourself in a hole every year because
then all your living is just crisis to
crisis to crisis life's too short for
that now you end up with a 15% interest
rate on a $40,000 suburban